welcome to ibm cloud labs an interactive
way to learn essential cloud native
concepts
all entirely through your browser
whether you're an experienced developer
or just looking to learn more about
kubernetes in the cloud
ibm cloud labs makes it easy to get
started
let's see how it works cloud labs gives
you access to a real
kubernetes cluster environment not a
demo
you'll get temporary access to a paid
kubernetes cluster
in an ibm cloud account to get started
click on the lab that you want to start
with
and then take a look through the
contents of that lab
and then you'll hit the launch lab
button on the top right
if you're not logged in already you'll
be asked to log in or create an ibm
cloud account
this part is quick and free following
that you'll have a fixed amount of time
to run through the lab
if you need more time to complete the
lab you may extend the duration by one
additional hour here's the best part
there's no prerequisite setup or tools
to install
all the tools you need are embedded in
the interactive terminal
directly in the browser you can follow
the guided lab
and then easily input commands from the
instructions
into the terminal once you've completed
the labs you can take the quiz
to earn a badge and show off your skills
to get started now
check out the links in the description
below thanks for joining us
and we hope to see you on ibm cloud labs
as always please drop a like or a
comment below be sure to subscribe and
stay tuned for more videos like this in
the future